You've seen some
different CSS properties.
And perhaps, you've even noticed
some commonalities between them.
For example,
properties like width, height and
padding all expect values
that express length.
And much like measurements in real life,
these properties use
units to describe length.
In real life, we use units like meters,
miles, feet, and
centimeters to describe length.
But in CSS, we use units like pixels and
percentages.
CSS units, like pixels and percentages,
can be categorized into two distinct
groups, absolute and relative units.
Absolute units refer to
fixed units of measurement.
Relative units refer to units that are a
comparison to another linked property.
Consider this example of a road.
If i'm describing how wide
it is an absolute units,
I would say something like
the road is 7.2 meters wide.
But if I'm describing how
wide it is in relative units,
I might say something like
the road is two car lengths wide.
A car length is relative to
the average length of a car, and
can change over time.
So how does this look in CSS?
If we look at this example,
we have a property width being
passed the value of 400 pixels.
400 is our number value, and
pixels is our unit of measurement.
Pixels are an absolute form of
measurement that corresponds to one
physical device pixel on your display.
Any modern screen be it a screen
on a mobile device, tablet,
laptop, desktop monitor, or television
is made up of millions of pixels.
We can use these pixels to define
exact links that we want to
pass to properties.
But pixels aren't the only unit
of measurement used in CSS.
There are actually a lot more.
For absolute units pixels
are the most common.
However there are others like
millimeters, inches and centimeters, but
these are rarely if ever used.
For relative units we already
know about percentages but
there are others like ems,
viewport width and viewport height.
Percentages are the most
common relative unit.
But you won't be using them for
a few lessons.
You'll use relative units more, when you
start learning about responsive design.
We'll stick with pixels for now.
For a full list of units, refer to one
of the CSS references in the text below.